[Music]  [Music]  well I'm Nordhoff with you or seal  tempers all the running them down  no stomach honor inaugural lighting at  the sickening up all our after to school  can Helen didn't Eric my name is  Christina Louis I'm a psychologist I  don't a lot of people are wondering what  happened last night with you and the boy  if you touch me you will burn  Eric your Embassy has sent some people  to take it back to America  [Music]  let's get in the car we cannot reach a  city you do agree with me right you've  seen what he's done here I saw it with  my own eyes  I look at to be alive sometimes I just  get these visions I see things well like  they're different world right I can walk  around I can touch things I can feel  things I feel the wind I feel the heat  I'm not saying he's a bad person I don't  care what he is  we need to get him under control  get out of there as quick as you can  [Music]  [Music]  I think something happened that nobody  quite understands yet  [Music]